قبل اشهر قليله كان دخول ذاكر الى مثل هذا
الدكان الصغير يكلفه اقل من 20 الى 40%
مما صار يكلفه الان
عشره الاف دينار او ما يعادل سته دولارات
هو ما كان يدفعه مقابل هذا الكيس الصغير
قبل اقل من عام اما الان فصارت قيمته
تعادل عشره دولارات فالمسواك كان يكلفنا
تقريبا 200 الف دينار هسه صار ضعف بال 300
الف دينار ناهيك طبعا عن المواد الخضره
واللحوم والدجاج
هوايه تكاليف تصير عن الكيان العراقي
بالنسبه للدخل المحدود بالنسبه للعامل
للكاسب اللي دخولهم جدا محدوده
هكذا هو الحال هنا في شهر رمضان الذي
يتزامن هذه السنه مع ازمه جديده في سعر
صرف الدولار وانخفاض اكثر لقيمه الدينار
العراقي
ومن هنا فتحت وزاره التجاره العراقيه
مراكز تسويقيه تضم بضائع وسلعا غذائيه
مدعومه وكل شيء داخلها يباع بسعر التكلفه
بمناسبه شهر رمضان هذه المراكز المفتوحه
امام الجميع ولا حدود لحجم التبضع وكمياته
اتصل بنسبه التخفيض بها الى اربعين بالمئه
بعض المواد تصل الى 25% يعني حسب الماده
وحسب كلفه السيراتها يعني على الشركات
معظم المنتوج محلي حقيقه موجود
ما زالت هذه المراكز محدوده الانتشار ما
يعني ان الاهاليه خصوصا من محدودي الدخل
لم يتمكنوا من الوصول اليها في مناطق عده
حاله الغلاء هذه تتفاقم في شهر رمضان
واسبابها متعدده لكن السلطات المعنيه
والمواطنين يعتبرونها استغلالا غير مبرر
من قبل كبار التجار
تقول غرفه تجاره بغداد وهي هيئه رسميه
مستقله ان السوق العراقيه تعتمد على
البضائع المستورده بنسبه تبلغ نحو 90% ما
يعني ان ارتفاع اسعار السلع او انخفاضها
مرهون اساسا بوضع العمله واستقرارها فضلا
عن عوامل اخرى
سامر يوسف الجزيره بغداد